how's it going guys we're back for some
more design patterns my name is matt
you're watching code tech tutorials
don't forget to like and subscribe for
code content we got a lot of these
design patterns to still visit so let's
visit today the facade pattern and we're
going to continue with our repo here
using cmake and i added a facade folder
up here all right so what we have here
with the facade pattern i'll explain
briefly is basically when you have some
sort of interface and you decide to kind
of simplify it with the interface on top
of that interface and that's why it's
called a facade this is very common to
the adapter the big difference is
usually the adapter is trying to fit it
to a certain situation for
another interface
whereas a facade is just kind of making
a simpler use case directly
but we'll talk about the adapter next
episode because this is they're often
the same thing even they're often both
nearly the same
and can be interchanged all right so we
got a main.cpp and we got a sod.h now
what i was thinking here is we'll take
uh the factory two remember back in the
day we made factory two this this old
repo and we have this armor so armor has
a base type here with a virtual override
of dawn armor so there's this armor we
have heavy armor we have medium we have
light now essentially these three
classes here are the interface right now
we just instantiate whichever one so
that's the interface so let's make a
facade over this heavy armor just as a
quick example so we got our previous
interface that we want to over i almost
said override but that's not the right
terminology we want to facade over so we
want like essentially it'll be
kind of an armor builder you would
almost call it at this point or whatever
you want it to be because essentially
that's what this does it it just
makes armor well instantiates armor into
your memory so one way or another it
does make armor but of course you would
adapt this to your objects for your
thing for whatever you're doing um
that's always the tricky part about
explaining these is uh
you gotta adapt it to your stuff right
all right well i guess it's not that
tricky all right so we're gonna include
armor we gotta we're gonna do this all
in the facade include
back a directory factory two armor.h
so we have all that stuff at the ready
then we're just gonna make a new class
and we'll just call this uh
i guess i could call it armor facade but
that's kind of a terrible name it'll be
i almost want to call it armor builder
but i feel like that's going to get
confused with some other
pattern but essentially this kind of
would be
almost a front end to a it's a well i
guess it's a facade over a factory so
it's still kind of a factory but i'm
just going to call it like an armor
builder facade so yeah we'll just put
all all that in there that that long
okay so let's work in here for a bit we
got private stuff we got public stuff
uh we need to decide what we want
publicly and privately uh publicly let's
see and privately well i think privately
we just want the different types of
armor so we're gonna go
so now anytime we want one of these
we want to be able to just call a public
function here and do it so
let's uh let's make our default
constructor here and our default
constructor let's even make these
pointers
and the default construct is well we
just want to instantiate these and
that's
really it
in this way so now
when we want armor
we can just
basically call this and do whatever
operation we want so we need to make the
public operations here
um that abstracted away like we'll just
make a let's do this i guess
is there any function let's see what's
private here in public let's look at our
armor one time uh this this string here
is public the armor type so we can
always get that out of these armors we
can always just grab that string and uh
that's what we want to make automatic
get
heavy armor
and we would just go
heavy armor armor type
this is a very contrived example as you
might expect so what's a complaint about
here no suitable conversion from string
to oh string pointer sure
all right
and we essentially want to do the same
thing for the rest of these yeah i guess
i'll just put it in here it's no real
shortcut in a very contrived example
considering we're just returning a
string of the type we could you know
essentially make a uh
just a string builder that does
something even more simple that's just
because armor doesn't do anything in our
example would literally just as a string
but if i had more stuff in here you
would work it up accordingly in your
facade like if you needed uh
special cases you could make it
construct properly
if you wanted it these honestly should
have something like at least an amount
of armor or something
uh about them but all they got right now
is armor type so that's why this is so
simple and so can try so hopefully that
resolves most the questions i'm going to
get right off the bat like why are you
just instantiating something to return a
string okay you get it but that's
essentially a facade you just put an
interface over something so let's make a
main here i've already got the file
included
just a client end
uh client test sure so instead of
including armor now since we're we got a
facade of it armor builder facade and we
don't even know about this armor class
that's that's kind of one of the points
there it just uh you don't even need to
know about the other thing
i'm gonna call it abs and
yeah that'll default instantiate right
there and uh we'll make all these now of
course this needs a destructor because
otherwise we're gonna we're gonna run
into troubles uh with memory leaks here
because obviously we're making these
pointers or setting up this memory when
we construct this class we don't have
anything telling this to clear when
we're done
we could also get around that by just
making these unique pointers and they'll
do that automatically but instead i'm
going to stick with the classic form and
just make a destructor that destructs
them when we're done and the easiest way
to do that is just called delete on all
these all these pointers
there we go now we could make this a
little better
for example we could make sure these are
not null before we call delete and we
could also
set them to null like heavy armor equals
null pointer so yeah
i saw also not just delete but we could
also null you can also check that
they're not null before going through
this whole process so this could be a
little better is the point but i'm not
going to put all that in here for
simplicity's sake but at least you know
all right well i think that pretty much
works up the facade um yeah if you if
you get to this and try this out try
doing this with a unique pointer and
notice that you don't need this
destructor anymore
that's kind of where i was going oh yeah
i guess we should actually uh
do a proper example here let's just
include i o stream so we can get an
output real quick
and
standard see how
now let's just do all the different
armor types dot all right and we'll just
copy this down
and just do all of them get medium armor
and just confirm that it builds them
correctly and gets the right stuff so
this is essentially a little unit test
that we're just doing with the console
visuals which is a terrible long-term
plan but hey it works in a quick pinch
just to make sure you got the right
results all right and now we're going to
go to our cmake stuff down here i just
kind of enabled the default stuff that
popped up for
visual studio and enabled cmake and the
visual studio c plus plus
visual studio code i mean this little
studio code so i'm going to set this uh
build to well let's see what we got here
we should have a new one here
or facade
oh okay no we don't yet i still need to
add it to let's see
we'll go over my cmake real quick we
have a very top level one this has a
version and a project and then adds
subdirectory design patterns so it goes
into this folder looks at the top one
here this is where we add all our little
examples so we need to add facade here
because that's the new folder
we added that has a new cmake so now our
new executable should show up after
things refresh and it looks like visual
studio auto refreshed so there we go
switch that to facade let's hit run and
we should see our armor types and hit
run it's just this little arrow down
here or you can do it as i did in the
previous episodes through the console
there we go we got heavy medium light as
expected
these are very frequently put over
libraries like for example when i work
on my game engine and i bring in a
library i'm usually making my own front
end of their library essentially and
that's essentially a facade or sometimes
an adapter talk about adapter in the
next episode so uh stay tuned and uh
thank you guys appreciate
all your input feedback support all that
stuff let me know your comments on
facades are there other ways to do them
i'm sure there are because there's a
static way is what as well this is just
a very like i said a million times a
contrived example but i hope that helps
yeah you understand the sod pattern if
you're trying to understand it
and i'll see in the next episode peace
out
[Music]